he thought he was okay they didn't even
treat him at the time out
but he just tried to signal to their
bench
norman powell has checked in and he gets
right to work
and then ibaka is going to play a lot
he'll play more than gasal does
norman powell's gonna play he just hits
a three there
so a three-point game what a shot and
what a finish
by davis dropping a sledgehammer
courtesy of our oculus front row view
raptors push the other way with ciacom
powell from three offensive rebounded
backhand he cleans it up
well their pace is great they haven't
been able to guard effectively at all
you know they're trying to play a little
bigger on ciacom
puts them mismatched in other places
obaka tough fadeaway
over the top of luau cabaret still no
official word on kyle lowry who left
this game early
or should i say late in the first
quarter a little bit of an ankle injury
ibaka is there to clean it up
rest in between this opening and second
round series
potentially against the celtics
absolutely
what an attack by powell who roots a
two-pointer
davis showing off the ball handling good
set up
and easy as pie for serge ibaka
showing some fight we've got chris
chioza
on serge ibaka powell dropping a hammer
now here's the dunk chioza
on ibaka alan jared allen just coming to
help just starting to come
how long is jared allen going to go
without a shot
he didn't have one in game three we're
halfway through the second quarter and
he doesn't have one
johnson triples around davis and then
tonight again abaca
doing it defensively
a pretty setup off the dribble timeout
brooklyn
it took him like five and a half
quarters to get a shot
and now he gets two on two possessions
but again ibaka
in low both teams playing a lot of zone
now
obaka left open boy it is target
practice for serge
ibaka are used to playing against bigger
people but they're still going to give
away
size every night terrance davis
on an open three
that's kind of become the new norm in
the nba powell
nasty indigelous
that is a great dunk but they're letting
powell get to his right hand
johnson misses the three offensive
rebound allen it's poked away taken by
the raptors
powell looking for more and he just
keeps on coming he's got
20 points attacks before the defense is
set
and makes a solid play and does it again
ciacom turning playmaker right here it's
one of only
four nets players to have scored 50 or
more points in the game and also
a triple double in their career the
other three are kyrie irving continue to
put
uh small guys on big guys chris chiosa
guarding siako now
well this is like an open gym night for
norman powell look the
nets are undermanned and they're playing
fast
offensively they've played okay but
defensively this
is open gym night 104 83
but you're right you're just an
infectious personality beloved by his
players and hopes that he'll get a
strong look for that long-term job in
the off-season
as he trails the play final 90 seconds
of the quarter
habakkuk again wow
as the raptors trying to put the
finishing touches on the nets final
seconds of the quarter
davis with the baker to beat the horn
dominating the brooklyn nets here in
game four
a 29-point raptors lead
the nba playoffs on tnt it seems surreal
in the aftermath and it still does all
these months later let's get more now
from stephanie
well one thing that kobe bryant was was
an advocate for women's
sport and a lot of people would say well
this guy's playing well
we have to play him nick nurse knows
he's playing well
knows that he quote deserves to play
promises to be a terrific second round
semifinal series
johnson into the corner this is thomas
getting a friendly bounce boston toronto
will be an absolutely great series two
teams who are both good
at both ends of the floor davis resets
here is boucher davis from deep
splash that is their 19th
three tonight thomas was signed for
wilson chandler who
opted out of the restart with the covert
19 situation as we saw a number of
players do around the league and
thomas trying to take advantage anderson
kind of got caught in midair turns it
over alice jefferson at the head of the
field
and the raptors just continue to pour it
on paul
watson
[Applause]
hollis jefferson running the break and
we've already said i think a big
advantage
for toronto is norman powell and serge
ibaka off the bench and some guys who
are very good off the bench and play
different roles but they're not going to
get that kind of
production say that he can play kyle
lowry will try to be out there heck we
saw today with the injury
he tried to not even say anything to
anybody and come back and play as we see
nurse asking for a little weave action
to run that clock and stanley johnson
filling it up from deep
coming together both the east and west
[Applause]
145 119 here is thomas
off the bounce